[Music]
hey I'm Adam I'm Evelyn and currently
we're in Venice we're about to go to
Desperados deep house party it's the
world's deepest man-made pool it's a
hundred thirty feet it's the deepest
dance floor in the world it's Peggy cow
the hottest DJ also believers yeah the
prettiest city in the world
grazie as part in the world anything
could happen it is under water under
water
let's go so we're currently getting
ready to leave for the party end
obviously I haven't disclosed this too
much but I am Peggy dues number one
biggest fan I'm a super fan like she's
probably the coolest person on the
planet if and when God willing when we
get to meet Peggy goo I'm just gonna go
completely off script and just ask them
to be my best friend because I think I
deserve I think it's time for me and
Peggy to borrow spiritually and we're
gonna see what happens
finally hair so excited
[Music]
[Music]
my god that was that which is so good I
mean you see the truth I think you
videod epaulette is super exciting go
you hear all of the music and you can
feel the face and literally all around
you
[Music]
I've got the chance to interview so my
first question is like when are you
gonna follow me on the ground I always
said to my friend the chemistry yeah
it's there or not there okay so I joined
this one I trained like something we got
I just need to speak to you maybe a
little before this place I eat it and
that was the most crazy ever but this
broke the record look at them this is it
this is it we've done the best I bet
thank you big crowd
sly my crown I can't even exaggerate
this isn't the best thing that we're
done and now we're gonna head we're
gonna peace out grace thank you I'm
gonna be dreaming up Peggy
[Music]